Did you say that I sniff out loud?
No,
but that's a good one.
Sorry.
Really like Quirky, unique,
fun and communicative
with a lot of love with a lot of love.
I'm going to play Africa by toto.
Oh God, I can't hear anything.
So this, let's do that. And He'd
hate to hear you say right now.
I'm tired of listening to Africa by toto.
By the very first time I saw a j
a I thought he was really nice.
He looked friendly.
So that's why we went and just chatted.
I didn't make the bed
this morning. Huh? Uh,
well I met her at an audition.
She recognized me and she's like,
are you a j Rafael? Um, I used to listen
to you in middle school. She said,
I was really hoping that she would like
tweet about me so I could find her.
Sounds kind of creepy.
Um,
I said that he was,
he looked very friendly
and I don't actually,
I don't think I said approachable,
but I meant to say look,
friendly and approachable is so that's
why we ended up chatting in the corner of
that audition at Disneyland.
Yes. What did she say? Ah, well,
I said I was really hoping
that you would tweet about me.
Oh my God.
Our first date was when we went
to see Jo Koy at the Improv show.
I was reading your lips.
She literally said this,
our first date was that a Jo Koy concert.
I think that's when I first made it
clear that like, let's make this a date.
I said, Joe Quigg concert.
Did you read that?
My, yeah, I said that. I said, Jo Koy.
He forgets a lot of his own schedule.
Like I try to plan things,
but then we forget that he has like
a shoot or something like that.
So it's kind of just comes down to like
him being a little bit disorganized,
but that would be just one
thing that bugs me a little bit.
Sometimes I have to be like to clean.
It's like I liked it.
Just throw my shoes at the
door or not make the bed.
She kind of nags at me
a little bit for that,
but it's fine is not even a big thing
really. It doesn't really buy. Okay.
The other day bothered me.
Did you say that I s I sniff out loud?
No,
but that's a good one.
Um, I said that you were a
bit disorganized. Okay. Yeah,
I know. It's just, I'm just so shocked.
I said one thing that bothers me is
that you don't let me be dislike.
I would just miss his presence.
I love when and where does hanging out.
We don't even have to be doing anything.
We could be working on two separate
things at the same time or just sitting at
home watching TV.
A lot of the little things in his little,
the little quirks and the little
weird things we do together.
A lot of like small things like,
like we make up a lot
of songs like every day.
If she was gone right now I would miss
her voice a lot because she already
doesn't sing that much when she should.
Wait was the question if you went away
forever or like a week because I think I
answered it as if it was like as if
you left for like a couple of days.
It was like,
I love things that he does a little things
also in the context where
I thought you were dead.
Oh, I didn't answer it like that.
Oh, I'm gone a lot. So like yeah,
you can handle a couple of days. Yeah.
That's why. That's why it was no big deal.
That's why I was like, I mean,
I wouldn't mrs like being there,
I think our biggest fight has been about
something in his past that I have had
issues or I struggled to let go of.
It was a big fight that
happened a while ago,
but it still comes up here and there.
A recent big one kind of stemmed from,
uh,
my ex girlfriend.
Um, yeah, I don't,
I don't know how much detail to go
into, but it just, you know, like the,
my past relationships or dislike a part
of me growing to be this man that I am
for her now. I think it's hard to
explain that perspective sometimes.
Like she cuts off for acts as
completely and doesn't talk to them.
A lot of people like hate the
people that they bid with. And it's,
it's hard to say that
because I don't hate them.
I just wish she understood how much I
love her and how much I see her as the
main person in my life, you know?
And I think she's seen a lot of that.
Whoever was like a main person in my life
and she is trying to fill their shoes,
but like, they're, you know, they're
part of my past and she is like,
she's my present and my future.
I said our biggest fight has
been about a face in your path,
but I saw it. I couldn't read your
lips. He said ex girlfriends. So
there it is. Yeah. I mean, that's just
the way you are with everything. No,
you're not a person to cut people off
and you continue to like maintain your
relationships at the end
of the day. Uh, I love you.
I'm sorry if it's a big thing.
I Dunno.
I'm going to cry. Well, I,
I mean, I just, I know I love
you. Like, I know it's not like,
uh,
it's not something that I'm going to just
let define our relationship and define
why.
Like we would end our relationship because
it's so like what we have is way more
than that. And even though we
have like bumps in the road,
I still love you and I'm always
going to live you. So yeah,
sorry, I'm crying. But yeah,
we struggle a lot. We do.
Um,
but we work on it and we get through
every five or every struggle and I know we
get stronger from it.
Um, I think maybe you don't
hear it enough for me,
but like they see a future with us.
I know
patience and learning that were
very different in the way we think.
Obviously you can't just
have one way of thinking.
You have to put yourself in the
other person's shoes. Balance.
I think the importance of quality time,
not just with us,
but like quality time with myself too,
and to be a little more organized.
We're not always going to agree on things,
but knowing that there's an end goal
and that we're still learning how to be
adaptable to one another
at the end of the day,
I think we both see a future with a
family and being married and all the cool
stuff that comes with being together.
Yeah,
it feels like our relationship
is kind of like an adventure.
Like I never really know what the next
step is where I've always been the person
to always want to know what the next step
is. But with him it's been different.
A lot of my friends and people,
I haven't talked to her a lot of time,
they see that I've like posted about my
girlfriend a lot and some they're like,
well,
I've never seen you post this much about
your girlfriend and things like that.
I think people see like how much love
I have for her and I think it's because
she's made me want to like be loud and
proud about who I am with her and and who
we are together.
I don't know.
I love how it feels so natural with you,
and I've never had a relationship where
it felt this natural before and it
happened when we didn't even expect it.
Even through all the ups and
downs and stuff, we still,
we still love each other through it.
You're worth every single
thing they go through.
We,
oh shoot.